I think we came up with a hot new legal
drama that people are gonna go
absolutely crazy for take a look your
honor esteemed members of the jury as
you judge this case considered the
defendant a man knowingly used this
toxic liquid right here in his textile
factory just to save a buck but also
consider that 15 Vietnamese workers who
lost their lives because of one man's
greed consider the life of the luck King
trim and the American factory manager
Michelle Reed who won't be home tonight
to tuck in her nine adopted Becca Stan
children Ella Beck Mary Jo Joel
banal mean we were so good come with
Dean
this wind and water it's very stem
[Music]
you are trying so les you alright I hope
there are more episodes of that show I
don't know if there will me but I just
hope there will